I asked you what I should be doing with
my life you said what you're doing right
now I think is pretty good and then you
said truth in the service of love what
do you mean by that that's a hierarchy
of virtue I would say you know there's
an old idea that God is the sum of all
that's good I don't think some is
exactly the right metaphor more like
imagine there are Eternal verities truth
beauty Justice love courage or attitude
passion think of all those things as
virtues so virtue is what all virtues
have in common that's the relationship
of God to the good God is the essence of
the good or you may think how would that
manifest itself in your life well that
might be pursuit of the good that's the
pursuit of the good that unites all
proximal good what is that exactly well
it's something like belief that it would
be for the best that all things flourish
to the degree that that's possible when
I was a clinician I thought of that as
the good in me serving the best in my
clients and I think the desire for that
to happen that's love